let's see if we can take this quadratic
expression here x squared plus 16x plus
9 and write it in this form and you
might be saying hey sal why why do i
even need to worry about this and one it
is just good algebraic practice to be
able to manipulate things but as we'll
see in the future what we're about to do
is called completing the square it's a
really valuable technique for solving
quadratics and it's actually the basis
for the proof of the quadratic formula
which will you which you'll learn in the
future so it's actually a pretty
interesting technique so how do we write
this in this form
well one way to think about it is if we
expanded this x plus a squared we know
if we square x plus a would be x squared
plus 2a
x
plus
a squared and then you still have that
b right over there
so one way to think about it is let's
take this expression
this x squared plus 16x plus nine i'm
just going to write it with a little few
spaces in it x squared plus
16 x
and then
plus 9 just like that
and so if we say all right we have an x
squared here we have an x squared here
if we say that 2 ax is the same thing as
that then what's a going to be so if
this is 2
a
times x
well that means 2a is 16 or that a is
equal to 8. and so if i want to have an
a squared over here well if a is 8 i
would add a
i would add an 8 squared which would be
a 64.
well i can't just add numbers
willy-nilly to an expression without
changing the value of an expression so
if i don't want to change the value of
the expression i still need to subtract
64.
so notice all that i have done now is i
just took our original expression
and i added 64 and i subtracted 64. so i
have not changed the value of that
expression but what was valuable about
me doing that is now this first part of
the expression
this part right over here
it fits the pattern of what of a perfect
square quadratic
right over here we have x squared plus
2ax where a is 8 plus a squared 64. once
again how did i get 64 i took half of
the 16 and i squared it to get to the
64. and so this stuff in this that i've
just squared off this is going to be
x plus 8 squared
x plus
squared once again i know that because a
is 8 a is eight so this is x plus eight
squared
and then all of this business on the
right hand side what is nine minus
sixty-four well sixty-four minus nine is
fifty-five so this is going to be
negative 55 so minus
55 and we're done we've written this
expression in this form and what's also
called completing the square